multiple sources tell Fox News that
President Trump today called his
embattled personal attorney Michael
Cohen no word on what they talked about
in that conversation but a phone call
from the president at Cohen becomes more
problematic with the revelation today
the Cohen is the focus of a criminal
grand jury investigation in documents
filed for a court hearing in New York
today prosecutors revealed that the
president's longtime personal attorney
Michael Cohen is being investigated for
criminal conduct that largely centers on
his personal business dealings Cohen's
attorneys are seeking a temporary
restraining order barring prosecutors
from using any of the materials seized
in a Monday morning raid until they have
been vetted for privileged
communications the government says they
initiated a search because Cohen was not
cooperating and there was a risk records
could be deleted the most intriguing
parts of the documents detailing what
the FBI was looking for have been
redacted but the court papers do state
that Cohen has been the subject of a
months-long investigation and that many
of the crimes he is suspected of have
nothing to do with his work as an
attorney stating Cohen is in fact
performing little-to-no legal work while
the FBI was looking for possible
communications Cohen had with the
president the documents disclosed that
zero emails were exchanged with
President Trump the attorney for stormy
Daniels who is battling with Cohen over
a non-disclosure agreement was also in
the courtroom today and says a criminal
investigation if Cohen could be bad for
president Trump clearly Michael Cohen
was his longtime attorney and
effectively probably knows where all the
bodies are buried as they say and I
think that in the event that Michael
Cohen is ultimately charged that that
could pose significant and very very
serious problems for the president
United States as the president was
watching events surrounding Cohen unfold
he was actively lashing out at former
FBI director James Comey in a book
coming out next week Comey uses harsh
language to describe mr. Trump writing
this president is unethical and
untethered to truth and institutional
values come he also mocks the
president's appearance writing his face
appeared slightly orange with bright
white half moons under his eyes where is
he placed small tanning goggles
president Trump ripto me on Twitter
calling him an untruthful slimeball that
it was his great honor to fire Comey
Comey reveals that in his first meeting
with President Trump the president was
fixated on an allegation in that
unverified dossier that he had hired
hookers in Moscow and had them urinate
on each other says he may want me to
investigate it to prove that it didn't
happen and then he says something that
distracted me because he said you know
if there's even a 1% chance my wife
thinks that's true
that's terrible the press secretary had
a particularly scorching assessment have
coming today the American people see
right through the blatant lies of a
self-admitted leaker this is nothing
more than a poorly executed PR stunt by
coming to desperately rehabilitate his
tattered reputation and enrich his own
bank account by peddling a blue book
that belongs in the bargain bin and
president Trump today issued the third
pardon of his presidency this time it
was scooter libby former vice president
Dick Cheney's chief of staff who was
convicted of lying to the FBI in 2007 as
part of the CIA leak investigation many
people believe that Libby was the victim
of a special council investigation run
amok drawing parallels to the Moller
investigation which President Trump
feels has now gone way out of bounds of
its original mandate Brett John Roberts
live in the North Lawn John thank you